the Hat you're wearing right now is
spectacular yeah no seriously it's
spectacular and um I can't look at that
if I put that hat on it's just look
what's gonna happen it's just not going
to work talk about Amish
we went through this a long time ago
when you had to do the 125th Street
shows at the Apollo now you gotta tilt
that hat if you're gonna tilt it tilt
that hat man what he tilt it and walk
well you had the perfect long face like
me yeah you gotta wear it you gotta wear
that hat yeah
this is too much of a pop no no no this
looks like I've been in a train accident
no you would know that's too much that's
too much the 1930s way too much of a
tilt right there you're okay you're
right all right all right all right I
gotta tell you gotta get it back up
again back up right there yeah right
here right there yeah okay you gotta act
like you gotta believe it if you don't
believe it I will never will
reject you I am not going to believe
this this is never going to work for me
see that's the kind of hat on you if you
don't wear it right that hat will
intentionally get blown away by the wind
but it looks fantastic on you and also
my problem too is I have a very uh large
head I know that the average person
looks at me and goes Perfection uh but
um but uh but no I have a very large
head and I can't just get any old hat I
need a hat maker to make me a hat you
need a custom hat made or you wear a
hoodie all the time you know
what I'm saying wait a hoodie I
can't wear a hoodie for the hoodie why
not I don't know
white rapper that's saying jump around
you know I just look do you know what I
mean some Boston guy in a hoodie we all
look the same you know yeah jump around
so this friendship thing this friendship
thing this is this is more this is about
you being in the right frame of mind
you're right your brain got to be right
you you too your brain too cluttered
your brain should be simpler you know
here's a perfect example you know what
your mechanisms is up right now
you know mechanisms are mechanism the
mechanism the mechanism is more specific
yeah I kind of understand the concept of
a Mecca this is the mechanism this is
how your brain is I feel your brain is
very limited in in the mechanism in your
head is is very limited and it's
simple but it like here's what it
is here's what your brain is right now
you go to the bathroom right yes and you
take the back of the uh you open
the back of the toilet tank you
know take that off right and you're
looking at right yeah we're
looking down inside yeah what's in that
it's a pulley it's a
chain yeah it's got them floaty yeah
it's a stopper stopping that
water up look at that water I'm
going to out right yeah yeah see
the brain is that's how simple
your mind is
[Music]
literally it's the mechanism of
that toilet bowl okay so what do I do I
mean if we took an MRI of your brain it
would be a Wonderland oh watch this
Wonderland It's amazing
going on in there amazing it won't
be that that simple ass right I
said more like a bidet I got a bidet
mine
I'm over bidet you're like one
of those really complicated Japanese
sophisticated bidets just where to aim
you know you ever get in one of those
showers they got like 14 shower
heads that's me that's me 14
shower heads watch my balls wash my
knees watch my feet watch my
back all my get washed
different sprayers that
do everything yeah and I can in the
bathtub
what kind of who wants to do that
this is metaphorically speaking that's
how my brain is That's How complicated
my brain is she yeah yeah you humble
minded yeah that's why you are limited
in your thoughts and that's why
you are still searching for a
friend
insulting interview I've done in a
almost a 30-year career I think you're
on to something I'm gonna tell you my
brain is complicated my is just
always moving and going my brain is like
a math equation you know my
brain is it's what my brain is and I
don't know you don't hear this a
lot you heard it when you was growing up
but you don't hear that no more
the bedroom and Theorem
remember that oh yeah the triangle
the background or his bedroom
yeah that right there that
math equation we learned in
school that we ain't gonna
never use again
Pythagorean and Theorem that you
about over here a say I'm
gonna turn around who the said
but background and Theory
math equations ever you failed that
class because of Pythagorean
theorem it's a mono the most complicated
algebraic
trigonometry equations it is the
last person Sona knows no I don't I
thought it was a squared plus b squared
equals c squared does any yeah yeah see
you know no no no no no
very good just don't act too happy about
it oh I'm sorry I never know anything
okay that's a that's a wonderful
equation but I is that thank you are you
are you telling us right now that
learning that equation was a major
stumbling block for you no it's not no
no it wasn't a stumbling block how
about saying all the time
Pythagorean theorem today is
that a problem once in a while I just
throw that out in in in the
conversation and watch my look
at me like what the was dead
see that's how my brain thinks that's
something I learned in fifth
grade and I had not forgotten that
that's the first time I
said that in 37 years but
the didn't go away see that's how
the brain works when you meet
cool people the feeling don't go away
somehow you have made it to this age in
your life where you have not been
blessed to meet people who have
touched you so much that you can
around and enjoy that you
still trying to find a friend
I'm sitting here throwing out the
Pythagorean and bear him in his
20 years ago I learned this